every what's up thanks for joining us
for another live signing typography
critique session and luckily we have the
pleasure of welcoming no kapu came back
to the show to help me critique the work
I found that our chemistry was really
nice and she brings some lovely
analogies and metaphors and some amazing
sound effects to talk about type and in
case you're wondering like how'd she get
so good at critiquing work well she's
been teaching typography for over 15
years at in both public and private
universities she's taught over 1,500
students she just told me right before
we went live on air Milka how are you
doing I'm doing great thank you so much
for inviting me over again appreciate it
I'm enjoying this yeah this is great
that we're able to teach not just the
the students our world in the class but
for everybody that's tuning in live so
welcome everybody that's tuning in live
via our facebook channel and I hope you
stick with us throughout the course and
we're gonna be doing this four more
times I believe for a total of seven
weeks we're in week 3 and for some
context all of our students whoever
enrolled in the class we're given the
exact same amount of copy and each week
they were given certain constraints this
week they're working with two point
sizes and one weight two point sizes one
weight and they're using Helvetica or
some version of Helvetica for some
people don't have access to it and we
understand that just do the best that
you can all right so we're gonna jump
right into I'm gonna share my screen
with you gonna go ahead and bring me
there and this week I'm gonna go down
the same path that I did last time which
is I picked out some examples of really
great design and and some designs that
are kind of unfinished maybe raw that
need a little bit more work and as
always I'll be your pilot for this
session I'll be driving the illustrator
project file and Milka can direct me as
she wishes and we're gonna get right
into it we're gonna try to cover as many
as we can in an in-depth way as possible
so we I know that like if i zoom out
here you guys will see how many really
great high-quality submissions we got we
got way more than this but I had to make
some hard decisions and I'm picking
things where I think Kankan with a
little tweak and use them can be
improved pretty quickly because
otherwise some of these layoffs would
take hours for me to work through to
figure out how to make it good the one
last thing I'll say this before we
jump into the critique is I just want
you to be open to the idea of exploring
not to sit here and judge whether each
design is good or bad
my whole intention is to show you that
there's a lot more to do with type than
what you think and if each and every
week you tune in and you try and play
along with us and you you're staying
open to this you may find that there's a
lot more that you can do and and
hopefully explore some really cool
designs with this simogo the first one
is from Ryan
Genki I hope I said your name okay I
didn't totally butcher it but Milko told
me before that she prefers critique work
without any name on it at all
because it's not personal it's just I
don't she doesn't care if you're man
woman child it doesn't matter who you
are she just wants to talk about the
work but I just thought that it's nice
for the people who are enrolled in a
class to see their name and and to kind
of know that that's them they can say
hey mom look my design was torn apart by
Chris and Milka see okay I like the
other side of the flip coin yes here we
are we have to point sizes and one
weight and this is from Ryan so I'm
gonna lay it out here one thing that my
wife reminded me to do is like don't get
into the details and all the technical
stuff talk about the overall composition
so one thing I'm gonna do today look at
another lady here and I'm actually I
like that about you Chris that you talk
about the details and I can do the
overall picture grace you have your
hands there to saj it I do you know I'm
gonna draw a box around the major design
components okay so that you can see
without looking at the details that
obscure it a little bit and as I'm
working through this now some of you
guys are gonna wonder like why use Adobe
Illustrator and why not use InDesign or
something that was made for page layout
programs and that's a very good question
and I'll tell you why one is because
this is the program I know how to use
that's it now I used to use page layout
programs but I don't use them on an
everyday basis we don't do a lot of
print design at our studio so I gotta
use something I know how to fly fast
with and I know how to use illustrator
really well for the most part okay so
now we look at the composition what I've
done is that blocked it all out and this
is a very helpful exercise for you to
kind of look at your composition almost
like an abstract painting this is kind
of what we're seeing so we're seeing one
two
three four we're seeing four elements
you could almost argue that these two
that I've highlighted here I'll switch
them to red so you can see him a little
bit better that that is really just one
element because they're a continuation
of a single idea just broken apart
whereas this is a different grouping so
if you follow along the idea is to kind
of create three focal points with one
major part where do we look first and
it's hard to see it like this because
this shape is very similar to this shape
and all I have to do is rotate it are
you going to see that it's very similar
in dimension right so if I I stacked it
next to each other you can see that
they're very similar this is something I
want you to be cognizant of not anything
necessarily bad per se but just be aware
that if we were to able to take this
block of information this one and make
it say three times as big
it changes the composition and it might
be more interesting if we were able to
take this and scale this down to a tiny
little dot oops how does that change the
feeling of this layout something to
think about okay so that's what we're
doing we're controlling and manipulating
information so that a it reads really
well there there's some visual interest
there's some creative tension that is on
purpose that's what we're doing so
that's all overall like kind of the big
picture thing
Naoko go ahead and do your thing and
tear it apart yeah thank you so much for
doing I really I really enjoy what you
did Chris they're just so extremely
talented I'm not just saying it because
we're online
you've always been extremely talented
and now I get to experience you in
action and it's just mind-blowing for me
so I think it's a treat it's a treat to
see you that this doing this and I want
to add to what you just said with what
you are talking about is adding depth so
by having small medium large we're
creating depth so it's like far away
closer and in front of you right so
that's one of the key elements of
creating a good hierarchy of typography
if I were to but by the way any of these
designs that we're talking about it's
not about that it's good or bad the one
of the reasons that I don't like to have
names on the work is because with all
due respect I want you all to feel that
as if there's an umbilical cord attached
from you to your work and you get grab a
scissors and you cut it up so this way
you're looking at all the work
objectively not subjectively does that
make sense and that's why I would prefer
not to know who did it
and I don't know any of you guys to be
honest with you but and at the same
token it is very important that we
acknowledge your hard work so I want to
give that kudos to you right now but
look at everyone's work as an example
where we can improve our work from there
from there what they did that was
effective and they come and productive
and also maybe it wasn't a good design
going back to that first design that you
were just talking about Chris I just
want to massage it a little bit more so
at the very top right where it says the
Journal for graphic design that little
for that little words for to me it's a
bit of an odd thing it's a preposition
and it's not that important so it
doesn't need to have all that attention
around it so what I and it's also a
widow so what I would also what I would
recommend is to have the journal for and
then hard return graphic design and this
way you don't have this odd shape of
space also yeah that's so good and the
other thing that I'd like to give bring
your attention to is all that space
around the word the drawing for graphic
design be aware that space is your
friend and using space effectively can
bring attention and hierarchy to what
you want to bring your attention to
because if you squint your eyes what is
the first thing you're gonna see boom
resonate right that's the first thing
you're gonna see but then your eye goes
up from features to journals of
design and the date and that really
sticks out because it's got all that
beautiful white space surrounding yet
and one more thing I want to go in there
and massage a little bit more is the
word resonate I like to see it tighter
in terms of turning it in I know it
looks like you have track you have
tracked it in and tracking is just to be
clear is the space between each
individual letter
so you're it's like a railroad track
you're tracking it out but kerning is
the individual space between two letters
nice job yeah I personally like to have
things tight tight tight tight tight and
if you look at like some of the missing
Mo's work work for Helvetica you'll
notice his - oh yes everything very
tight tight letting tight tracking and
especially when it's large it looks
really really good so I want to see the
space between the Z and the endless and
I want to see that it's also closer to
the line that says features don't be
afraid of having things get really close
when you're creating a focal point ah
beautiful very nice I'm not sure about
the space on the other side of the are
now I may take the whole thing and
increase it in size but now I love the
relationship between the n the capital n
and the line that says features now it
looks like they're supporting each other
they are like two good brother and
sister so there's something here you can
do you could take these both and you the
files built in a funky way I could tell
already right now and you could also try
reducing it and seeing how that impacts
the few links so we could still keep it
close and create more negative space run
the R or we could we could fill it all
the way up like we were here it's up to
you to decide I noticed a couple things
I did copy and paste this in and before
I figure out how to copy and paste and
keep everything in place is that the the
alignment of the left edge of
are you you have to pay attention to
that I'll show you what I mean so at
some point we go beyond the natural edge
of the R and we start to eat into it if
you keep pushing now I'm gonna push it
to its extreme here where it looks like
that sometimes when you push things off
the edge it creates a like a little
skinny shape and it throws off the
beauty of the letter form I just want
you to be aware I'm not saying this is
good or bad but for you to become aware
of this so that the alignment and how
you cut things off is really kind of
very intentional now I'm gonna pick up
the ball here because Luca had kind of
put us in a pretty good direction and I
thought these two blocks of information
this and this are very kind of similar
to me and I wanted to see if I can push
the contrast a little bit so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to try to just
break this and do a hard return for each
word to kind of make it skinnier
I want more contrast between this type
and the block of information below it
and now I'm creating something much more
vertical and much skinnier so if we were
to go through that same exercise that we
did earlier blocking out the shapes
which I did here I'll copy that over
here okay hang in there with me hey
Chris I think YouTube's throttling High
Definition on the stream so if any
chances you're working on small text if
you could zoom in yeah it's cuz
everybody's live-streaming cat videos
right now that's the price we all pay I
Chris have we talked about laws of third
no I think we have but you could talk
about it I'm sure you just did it you
just had laughter when you had if you
take the vertical line and take it all
the way straight up yeah you can you can
take the bottom vertical line and extend
it all the way to the top mm-hmm what
vertical line this they had the black
box exactly the black box yes yes so as
you can see there's a crisscross
happening here so that crisscross where
we have if pretend that was a straight
line as well Chris look could we do that
as well could we make it Chris
make the horizontal bar all the way go
across beautiful so as you can see it
almost looks like a gift-wrapped type of
a thing but but the law of third is very
powerful because the force of the big
white space coming down and with the
push and pull of the little white space
on the top right corner coming in
creates this beautiful focal point where
the eye really likes and that makes it
dynamic this is a good kind of a formula
for an asymmetrical design layout if
you're interested to learn more about
that hmm so let's do this if we were to
draw a box over this whole thing I'm
gonna color this red or something in
fact why don't we do this why don't we
do everything Center and then let's push
it over that's even more effective you
want to do this like this yes everything
Center yeah okay I mean if you if you
want to start with a blank page actually
okay how can I do that thank you I have
a lot of blank pages to work with but we
will do this we can do it let's zoom out
over here zoom in nice all right so you
want to try to start this in the center
actually we can delete that whole text
if you don't mind
sure and then let's let's draw a
straight line black beautiful and then
straight a horizontal one in addition to
the vertical one so this is called
symmetrical symmetrical layout design
right everything when you divided it in
half the right side is equal to the left
as well as the top to the bottom right
yep so what what happens if you take
that verdict and also look at the white
space next to each layer it's all equal
right yeah okay so symmetrical design is
nice for something that is traditional
something that is about stability a lot
of banks you know financial companies
benefit from a symmetrical design in
general we're speaking but what if you
want to make this more dynamic what if
you take that straight
line the vertical line and push it
either to the right or to the left
either right either side nice and then
we're gonna do the same thing with the
horizontal bar and either push it up or
down either ways is fine a little bit
more a little more please okay this is
called law of thirds basically what
you're doing is you're dividing your
page into thirds and you're focusing on
the one-third versus the three versus a
2/3 yeah and what does another thing is
happening is look at the beautiful
direction of the white box in contrast
to the direction of the white box on the
Left Chris if you can point out it with
your pointer so people can see that this
one the white box that I'm sorry the
white rectangular box at the top the
horizontal rectangular box aha in
contrast the direction of the vertical
box to the left yes no never mind that
one we're going to talk about that one
yes that one yes so the long vertical
rectangular white box in contrast to the
long horizontal so that we're having
directions here right so that's contrast
of direction now here's another
beautiful thing that's happening you're
having this massive white space okay at
the bottom right because if you could
point out it there AHA that is forcing
pushing itself towards that towards that
area against that little tiny white box
at the top left mm-hmm so beautiful
thank you Chris you read my mind yes so
you can you can point at it yes you can
you can draw a straight line with an
arrow to show that how it is forcing
mm-hmm okay does that make sense yeah
come on I can do it I can do it drawing
next time yeah I can do it drawing now
yes you can I have to let me grab my pen
back okay so she's talking about
directions so what I wanted to do is to
kind of do this for you so you guys can
see this right so I'll put this here and
just to become more aware of space and
how you use space
and so there's different kind of energy
and tension but when everything is
symmetrical and centered it's very
stable
I find it sometimes to be quite boring
and it's fairly easy to do all you do is
take all your stuff and just align it to
the centre vertically and horizontally
and you're kind of done well Milkha's
busy getting her pen and paper I was
gonna go back to my original layout here
and kind of show you what I wanted to do
here Chris I'm back and I think you from
what I saw you did it you got it that's
it perfect okay if you just use more
words I can draw what you want
you think boxes there's four boxes I
don't know which one you know got it let
me see if I can do this correctly
okay so we have you guys can see so we
have this I'm gonna do a square just for
the sake of it so we have this box and
what we're saying is we're drawing and
we're moving this straight line to the
side and then we're moving the straight
horizontal line to the bottom so we kind
of be creating some kind of a focal
point here why because you've got the
contrast of vertical contact samsara
horizonte direction versus the vertical
direction and then now you have the
contrast of big white space pushing
against a small white space so for that
reason you're able this becomes your
focal point
all right does that make sense yeah I
I'm doing this all reverse so let's see
back into what I was going to say that's
what we're talking I we talking about
contrast strike contrast of size
contrasts of direction and in the first
exercises everybody dealt with contrasts
of space right so let's continue using
that even though we're moving into other
parameters where we're using contrast of
size and weight yes okay so yes it was
thank you very much so
one other thing I want you to look at is
if we break this piece of information
the Journal for graphic design into
single words we could do that and if one
of these things bother us we can make
2018 longer or shorter just by deleting
things if we wanted to or breaking it
into two lines if we wanted but here's
something else I want you to think about
when when Milko was talking about
kerning and tracking the other thing
that we can play with is letting the
space between lines so you know on the
Mac and Macintosh keyboard if they hit
option and down arrow I start to open it
up and so I just want you to be aware
like what happens when I open this up it
gets a lot airier it does make it longer
more vertical it starts to repeat the
dimensions of this and you may you may
enjoy that you may think oh that's kind
of interesting it's similar but
different and I'm realizing there's an
extra space here somehow there we go
okay that is similar but different a
converse that you can go the other
direction and just tighten it up and
make this a lot more dense so when we
Millcote was talking about massimo
McNelly kind of playing around with
really tight things this may be one one
one notch too tight but I just want to
show you what that looks like now we
haven't really changed anything about
the letter form seems that we didn't
change the weight or the point size but
by changing a spacing we make something
much more dense and then therefore
blacker than it normally is just because
we've lost some of the white space okay
so I want you guys to think about that
and explore that so we can open it up we
can tighten it those are things that we
can do alright great suggestions okay so
let's move on because we have a lot to
to look at here I'm gonna switch it up
I'm not gonna go left to right I'm gonna
try one where it's kind of like
different
so this is from Andre ermine and let's
take a look at this so we have something
I think that is very symmetrical
relatively speaking and I will draw some
arrows here or a box let me try and draw
a box here so I'm gonna take this
draw a box like that and um I expand it
over here and I'll just take these two
points and hit command J and join them
together and it'll give me a solid right
so if I take this and hit rotate and
hold that option shift I'll get the
other side of it and I'll scale it so it
is actually quite a symmetrical layout
but what they've done was Andre has
rotated it off axis so it creates
illusion that it's not symmetrical but
it is actually quite a symmetrical
layout there's some interesting things
going on here so I turn it back over to
millcote what do you want to say yeah
III wanna first of all I want to give
kudos for trying to tilt the page versus
having it all you know horizontal
vertical but at the same time be aware
of things that are almost this piece is
almost Center almost symmetrical right
yeah because we have one one line we
have a line on the right side and we
have two lines on the left side so it's
like you know what you want to do I when
I see work like this I get the feeling
that the designer is very enticed to go
outside their comfort zone but they're
not sure they're not sure so it needs to
push itself and maybe if we look at more
work that our experimental work if you
look at magazine especially fashion
magazines I have such good typography
you can expand your horizon upon what
else can you do and I hope that example
that we talked about helped you a little
bit more but Chris continue with that
please yeah so what I'm gonna do is I
want to change this up just a little bit
because I think no clothes right it's
like you're in that no person's land
where it's like it's dynamic but it's
still conservative like what are we
doing here so one one thing that we
talked about before which is just to
change the way this information looks
having a harder time selecting things
because it's all on a weird angle but if
we were places with a period and we put
some space sorry guys
yes maybe this starts to look a little
bit more different so instead of
creating one horizontal line I'm
creating two blocks information I want
to try this I think these two things I
want to try it shipping it this way and
asking myself how does that feel I also
want to shift it the other way and
asking myself like does that feel better
and you know this every time you move an
element you have to move other things to
create more interest so what if I really
a lot more space there so what I'm
really trying to do here is to open up
this volume here relative to this one
down here so the more contrast that I
can drive between those two volumes the
better yeah okay so now this becomes 2/3
the size of this and this becomes 1/3
the size of that I think it works a
little bit better so we can keep it and
when we are opening up more parameters
and you can include rules shapes and
things like that you get so many more
toys to work with that layout like this
will become a lot easier to resolve and
Chris may I add one more suggestion if
we zoom into the world where says the
Journal for graphic design ok so I want
to ask you a question which direction is
that facing is it up or down it's facing
down I think it's down do we want upward
mobility or do we want downward mobility
well it depends on if we're talking
about finances upward okay so in general
be aware of that in general you want to
have your type read towards up not down
because down is negative so we want to
flip that around the journal for graphic
design in fact I would like to see that
graphic of journal design maybe in a
perpendicular axis to the n8 but maybe
in a straight line possibly and then
align itself with the word features ok I
could do that so we're talking about to
a couple different things here so which
way it is the type Reid I've always
referred type according to you to look
down not up because I'm looking from top
to bottom left to right but that's just
how I've been trained but
you know everybody can have a different
viewpoint in this but now what we want
to do is make this perpendicular so I'm
gonna rotate it like that and you want
to make this on one line right look
before we do that let's just take a look
at it so kind of interesting things
already happening here now this feels a
little out of place but whatever okay so
you want to see this on one line right
yeah yeah possibly one line yes it's
beginning to massage itself and I hope
this is making more sense so we are
beautiful look at that do you see how
everyone sees how that that laughter
that I was drawing for you it's coming
into shape where you have the big white
space versus a little white space and
you have directions of boxes vertical
versus horizontal yes mm-hmm
my trap strike is making sense should I
dry it out
no we understand it got it okay okay
cool so let's let's bounce around again
there's there's a bunch of last two I
want to talk about this one from Connor
: there's something's in in here this is
one of the first examples that I've seen
that used lighting so this is an
illusion obviously it's a trick because
there's no lighting here it's just all
flat two-dimensional representation but
by having resonate fall-off into
blackness it feels like there's more
here the feel it feels like there's a
layer in which most of the information
sits on the right third and it's above
this and it's casting a dark shadow
obscuring the light so there's something
cool about this now need some work need
some help so okay what do you think what
should we do here okay I'm sorry I'm
gonna give you some tough love here okay
you can't hear me yes we can hear you
can hear okay I'm gonna give you some
tough love yet right now we're focusing
on hierarchy of typography right excuse
me what I see here is dealing with
texture texture comes later I'm sorry
texture comes later and when we start
doing experimental that's when you can
go in there and experiment with texture
right now we want to learn about
principles of design and what our
principles
designs unity balance rhythm hierarchy
proportion emphasis focal point contrast
contrast is the mother of all excuse me
let me make it politically correct it's
the parent of all heard of all right
Chris what time it's not a wrong I'm
good with that so I like to see what
he's doing right now later on when we go
into the experimental because right now
what I really care about is that the
students are very much secure about
learning how to deal with black and
white text and know how to deal with the
elements of design and let's talk about
element of design what are elements of
design lines
shape in our case its typography right
because if you put shape and line
together you create typography you have
images images can come later on when
we're dealing with experimental you're
dealing with weight right now you're
dealing with size okay it's space that
does that make sense so at this moment I
don't know if I want to talk about this
in terms of texture and value because at
first I want to make sure that everyone
is very confident about how to deal with
the composition first before we getting
involved into texture and value because
takes your value gives you a break
you're allowed to cheat
legally yes I'm curious to know if we
take that word resonate and make it
solid white what would happen okay I am
going to delete let's see what's
happening here oh okay you see now you
took the makeup off this is what happens
when you take the makeup off you see the
real face
so let's critique that now before we put
makeup on the fact that it's also
reversed that's another layer of makeup
you've partly put foundation on if I may
speak metaphorically
mmm this foundation going on here but it
is what it is so let's let's move
forward with it okay hi Chris how do you
feel about some of the alignments maybe
it can help us with how we're the
january/february general graphic allies
with the crossbar or the arms of the e
extending itself out it doesn't really
so that's the thing so if we pull out
the rulers and I drag this thing down
you can see it doesn't line up so it's
kind of near it not quite on it so
there's some things to work out here so
when when Milka is talking about these
fundamental principles I thought overall
this is actually a pretty successful
layout in my opinion so there's two
columns here for the features and then
there's some pretty good hierarchy I
think this is like your while element so
I'm gonna remove this off screen here
let me just take this table all right so
this is a pretty straight clean layout
there's some issues here already because
I would probably put the journal for
graphic design above the date that would
just be me but I see why you do this
because this is a single line and it
creates a nice rhythm for you but for me
in terms of hierarchy I would have
changed it so that it's like this so we
read this first then we see that's
January February 2018 okay so that's one
thing I would do it seems like this is
using again gray okay great yeah yeah so
if we made it we could switch the route
to to white scale again let's take the
makeup off
while my transparency yes that's right
here and folks ask yourself this
question how can I create the depth that
I'm trying to create with greyscale with
size and weight yeah you know what my
illustrator is not responding so I'm
gonna save this file and you talk for a
little bit and I'm gonna just quit and
restart ok ok so let's folks let's
revisit some of the signifiers visual
signifiers that I was talking about the
fundamentals of design we have elements
of design which is line and you guys can
write that down shape in our cases
typography shape and form images or
graphics patterns space texture or value
and color and we're going to get to
those as the exercises move forward and
what you want to do is you want to use
element of design in conjunction with
principles of design and what are the
fundamentals of principles of design
unity or balance how do you create that
with perspective and distance rhythm how
do you create that with movement
repetition and direction balance how do
you create that as we talked about
symmetry versus a symmetry hierarchy and
that's what exactly what we're doing
we're creating order of higher towards
the first reach that can read third read
using all these principles of design and
next scale and proportion which is
really really crucial here and this is
how do you create emphasis can you
create it with contrast can you create
it with position can you create it with
different sizes color shape and style
focal point one of the very important
elements how do you create focal points
I haven't seen focal point as much yet
how do you do proximity how do you do
grouping and now that you guys are using
different sizes large versus small what
if they come
together and that's how you can create
focal point by grouping them and last
but not least contrast and we can go on
and on with contrast contrast of space
contrast of position contrast of form
contrast of Direction contrast of
structure contrast of size and so on and
so forth
case you want me to continue talking I
can't for like 4 of me figure out why
this type is gray it's not transparent
because I look at the transparency
setting it says it's a hundred percent I
think if you selected I see and double
click on the color I think it's a dash
of a color aha yes double click yes
you're right it is no white I can't
figure it out
there's something going on there some
some witchcraft but whatever I'm gonna
just leave that alone for right now it's
not a transformer there's nothing there
but anyways let's get back into it so we
have this type which let me just bring
it back in so this is a great example
where you can play around with proximity
and grouping right now where it's
sitting it's saying
mimimi but then what if we bring this
big gigantic mini-me and give it support
fan support where it says the in this
issue that whole entire column what if
you bring resonate and align it next to
that so we have resonate which is really
really big yeah but see no one bring it
which is really bring it down let's
bring it all the way down and I also
want to get all that space taken out
there letting the tracking just make it
nice tight tight tight tight tight
uh-huh you see that it's like now you're
running for presidency and you have your
fan right next to you next to us there's
also things that are happening here so
such colorful commentary I'll be the
play-by-play you're the color
commentator nice nice beautiful good job
beautiful and the other thing we can do
here is is I love how that
eight Peaks out we can also bring the
eight back in from the top to pick in so
this way your eye circulates around ah
gorgeous and you might say hey Milkha
you said don't repeat because it's
creating texture we're not repeating
here actually we're really bringing back
the rest of the information back into
the page a little bit more of the egg
because right now it looks funky I would
probably push and pull move it up in
that AHA alert and then less yes
yes what do you think Chris I don't know
I like that we're not playing around
we're exploring ideas about using the
entire page and repeating elements that
bleed off and recycling the other parts
that we don't see so we could take this
and this and we can just move it until
you find a happy place I thought this
was quite nice I don't know if we need
this part but it's an idea it's an idea
that we're playing with right yeah it's
an idea exactly it's just a suggestion
folks and then now since everything is
relatives when we move something
everything else changes right so now you
want to go back to where can I move the
paragraph that says in this issue mm-hmm
and how do i align it with the letter e
and the end shall I box it in in that
area or shall I have it extend all that
all of itself out of the page like that
number eight is doing it these are some
of the questions we need to ask from
ourselves and you never know till you
try it
otherwise we can talk about it talk
about this so the cows come home
right yeah so I'm gonna do some people
on the internet are saying it's very
hard to see so I'm gonna try and use a
bright color and see if this helps
I don't know if it will are the
suggestions and the analogy is making
sense to the folks I'm curious to learn
about that yeah you'd have to read the
comments if you open up your YouTube and
just make sure the audio is down you can
read the comments and that you interact
with them if I was hoping try to drive
this one to help you yeah I was hoping
Marc without that okay so some things to
think about here I
I personally I'm just gonna remove this
right now because it's not fully
resolved but I think this is pretty
resolved I think we still need to kind
of figure out the rhythm between this
and the rest of the nation nice line
this perhaps perhaps with the top of the
e or we want to talk but we don't
anywhere near it okay so it's like it's
either on or it's off that's it
good job beautiful ah
beautiful you know whatever you want
okay now in regards the whole gradation
thing whether or not you could do this
or not I I actually I'm gonna go against
my my co-teacher here I'm gonna say go
ahead and explore guys but don't use it
as a crutch if you haven't figured out
the fundamentals of design yet by
escaping into transparencies and
textures and lighting effects and and
photographic effects you may not master
the fundamentals so that when you get
into the experimental stage you're gonna
be a little lost so try to work within
their strengths as best as you can but
if you feel like you've got that and you
want to try hey it's giving us something
to talk about otherwise all the layouts
would be exactly the same so what I'm
gonna do right now is I'm gonna try
something else because I've seen this
done very effectively so if I go and
give this a gradient okay and then I'm
gonna go and make this multiply switch
it over here which will only darken it I
think I can I can see that the
background sound fully black there I
mean let me make sure the backgrounds
black
there now it's really black
so I'll lock the background again so if
we play around with this and we start to
play around with the lighting effect so
I'm gonna make it a little bit more
dramatic let's just say it goes halfway
and I'm gonna make this darker so I
think I go into gradient I'm gonna move
the right point over and maybe make a
transitional that's too much
nice very nice I really like it no like
I want to play around with it right so
if I were to take this box and duplicate
it over each letter I have more control
over it than just applying a basic
gradient on top right and now it's gonna
create a whole different feeling a
different effect altogether and I've
seen Awards books do this and it creates
this sense that the typography is
tilting towards the light and their
illusions that you can play around with
so once we figure out how to create a
dynamic layout where things are aligned
properly and there's good hierarchy and
spacing go ahead and play go to town I
encourage you to do it okay right but if
you don't do that and alignment is
whacking the spacing is weird then
you're just putting a band-aid on top of
a problem and you don't want to do that
I want to show you one other thing these
things have been done very effectively
I'm not telling you anything that has
not been done before and you could try a
horizontal one and it'll create a
totally different effect it's it's this
illusion that you're creating here and
sometimes these can be very cool and you
do the same thing again
so I'm duplicating that very cool what
Milka I at the end of the day what we
want to do is instill with you really
good design fundamentals that you can
grow and learn and really master the
layout game but also just to show you
options at the world in which you've
been playing in has been fairly small
that it's a huge beautiful playground
and go and explore build some beautiful
sandcastles and have fun okay awesome
all right let's keep Rocking okay let's
jump to this one this one is from Cole
Fraser and let's just take a look at it
now this person Cole is employing a lot
of the principles that you're talking
about the ability to wrap text around
the other side so starting with resonate
nice big bold cutting across the right
edge bleeding into the left and wrapping
around
I like that quite a bit and also this
list in this issue the list ops at Paul
ran but it keeps going down from the
bottom to the top very dynamic layout
good use of space overall how do we make
it better Milka
good question first of all as I
mentioned this before when you increase
the size of a text what else are we
increasing we're also increasing this
space in between each letters so that's
that would be the first thing I like to
say I'd like to see that resonate be
nice and tight tight tight as tight as
possible without touch me with touching
slither of attack don't touch yeah
gorgeous
and then then an 1/8 and also a little
bit closer to each other please it's
good beautiful and then can we make the
letting also the letting the space
between you we can just get it to touch
because do you want it that tight or you
want it less tight ok not bad maybe I
would play with that a little bit more
maybe go further in cuz AHA yeah down a
little bit maybe just just look at stop
yeah good good maybe one point up days
one or two point up keep going keep
going keep going
so thank you
no it looks like a bunny bunny ear ok
what do you think I don't know so yeah
these are decisions that every designer
has to make how close how far is it
creating a relationship is it creating
distraction is a trap to space but
things to look at so Milka lights really
typed letting light really like
especially why it's large especially
when it's large because what happens
again our I goes to the space in between
and we don't want that we want the eye
to focus on the shape and the form of
the letters right rather than seeing
this face in between yeah and then the
other thing I like I really like this
composition good job beautiful contrast
and beautiful usage of direction and
random so we have a line to the left and
we also random random
which is resonates right yeah thank you
and syllables so that's fine all right
that's good so how can we make this more
dynamic what is Chris yes we checked a
paragraph at the very bottom and then
move it underneath the letter 8 or
underneath the stroke of the right side
of the letter n just this out no no the
paragraph they lock the long paragraph
at the very bottom that has the names of
the designers not the top one just the
bottom right just the bottom line what
do you want to use let's move it either
under the stroke of the letter e or
under the stroke of the letter n no no
keep it where it was before all we're
doing is hold the shift key as you hold
the shift key just move it to the left
yes yes and let's take a look at yeah
where yes I did that is I don't like
yeah let's move it underneath the letter
stroke of the end
okay okay now can we cover the journal
for graphic design right now could we
take that out because it's right now
it's it's it's not right okay
so what do we do here we did the push
and pull effect so the top paragraph is
pushed and the bottom paragraph is
pulled so there's a push and pull
do we see that now what I like - you see
that right yes yes yes no okay what I
like to see is to see the bottom pie
graph come up a little bit higher
because it's - away from the from the
resonate
okay oops um yes beautiful but also well
and I like how I that was a beautiful
mistake I like how the word
january/february also brought itself up
higher than the paragraph nice
that's another push and pull now let's
select both paragraphs January and in
this issue and then bring everything
down a little bit
these are just little little notches
little okay we can wherever yeah good
job Chris beautiful now do you see how
does the Harrises working out for you
I like what you see here it's like this
is ed the letter Z right so it's not
just shifting on one axis you're
shifting on the other so it's we're
shifting off the page and then we're
shifting it left and right horizontally
and breaking that I think we need to
spend a little bit more time figuring
how to get this to work because I feel
like where it begins here between these
two paragraphs of information down at
the bottom is a little bit yeah J hangs
over but the idea is quite yes yes we're
looking at overall exactly thank you for
pointing out the little details because
I can I'm too far when I don't know yes
yes access to it but thank you for
bringing that up you're absolutely right
we go there and then we refine those
little details as Chris just mentioned
but if you look at this as an overall
picture we try to create dynamic and
this page we just pushed it a little bit
more to create that bling zoom effect
that so it's like a zoom coming in zoom
coming out now if you it's like it's
like a highway it's like so if you bring
the the title in now in this graphic
design deficient in this issue yeah
Chris I'm gonna throw that on you
because that this is some detail where
would you say I like to see it
vertically somewhere else or maybe
horizontally but where would you suggest
that to go as a let's consider this as
our satellite if it's our satellite
because it's so small where can we put
it
I don't know so you're saying take these
things killing my hair so let me hide
that you're saying you're talking about
taking this and breaking out of this
grouping right no there was something
else I asked you to take out it was what
was it all this journal of graphic
design yes thank you the journal I'm
sorry I can't read I apologize I always
see shapes and forms okay there you are
it's here yeah the line to that but I
don't know if it does anymore no it
doesn't so it looks like yeah it looks
like a lost soul to me it's it's sitting
there nobody wants it and it doesn't
know where to go what to do it doesn't
have any connection where can we find a
home for it I
No so let's push it oh that's a nice
place but what if we push it all the way
to the far right right okay ah now this
is where the satellite comes in because
now what happens is your eye keeps
coming into the page and goes out of the
page in from the top added ad from the
satellite comes back in from the bottom
so there's all this beautiful internet
that's happening did you see that now so
what's the focal point here now we have
the focal point of the axis of the
resume and you have the focal point of
the white space yeah next to it I'm a
very dynamic I'm gonna color this so
people can see this a little bit better
hopefully so let me get into the stroke
here
Milka can you describe a little bit more
what you mean by push and pull thank you
okay push and pull so so that's exactly
what we do if you take a paragraph and
then you take a portion of it and you
push that and then you take the bottom
paragraph and you pull it or pull it so
it comes push and pull or push and pull
so it's like a rubber band you're you're
pulling it and then you're also pushing
it I don't know if that helped because
you can't use the same words to describe
the concept you know what this is a
great example that we're seeing right
now there's a lot of push and pull
happening yeah because we have a focal
point where it's pushing it and it's
pulling it I know my hand is going
different directions I'm running out of
battery let me go put my charger and I
come right back is that okay yeah we
have no choice we need you to have
batteries okay so let's look at this
together so III can see that people are
having a hard time seeing because the
the quality of the stream is so low
because everybody's streaming right we
get that so let's look at this res
bleeds off the right edge and it
continues
as one thought and I can change the
color of these arrows to tell you that
these are different ideas so I mean let
me change that to like we say blue Chris
do you even need that top one it looks
like a continuation of yeah we don't
right now Jonah okay we're not supposed
to have it in there because I should
have me shoot the way that this
paragraph is it's just annoying me it's
just grabbing more than it's supposed to
okay so it used to be like this right
where it ended on Paul ran but because
we wanted to move it up to kind of just
explore the relationship there so then
that now has been restored but you
shouldn't repeat that information just
because so now that Paul ran is cut off
you can continue it up there so I wanted
to show you that there's this
relationship now traditionally the way
that we do this is we make that kind of
in alignment but what Naoko was talking
about you could take this and you could
drive it somewhere else like you could
bring it over here under the end if you
wanted to and then the audience should
be able to figure that out now what I
wanted to do was to continue this
thought here where as we read resonate
the journal for graphic design there
probably should be some relationship
between these things so I'm gonna bring
my guides back and I'm gonna bring this
down to snap to the bottom of this the
baseline of the end okay and I have to
kind of see like how does this relate
it's very hard to see but I'm gonna
bring it up so that the baseline of this
meets the baseline at the end okay
another thing I want to do probably is
to tighten up the letting there's just
too much letting for me because these
are meant to be read as one idea so when
you increase the amount of space in
between stuff you say they're not as
related as we think I'm not saying this
is a perfect way to resolve the journal
for graphic design but that's a way to
tie it together with this the next thing
that you probably want to do is to look
at with I'm gonna use my other pointer
here the resonate the way your eye would
normally go to resonate it could either
go here the journal for graphic design
but most likely it's gonna go down here
this continues right here and then it
goes to the right so just to kind of
think about like where somebody's I may
or may not go and allow that to kind of
inform the design decisions that you
make we're spending a lot of time on a
few layouts here and we may need to move
a little bit faster but we'll see why do
you guys let us know in the chat go
faster go this pace or go even slower
let me know what you want and just put
in the chat right now mark will do an
informal survey poll and he'll just see
how we're doing
I want to activate the group that's
tuning in live our live students who are
in here with us do you guys have any
questions so far
about what we're doing the decisions
that we're making and how else we may or
may not be able to help you go ahead and
raise your hand visually or just unmute
yourself and say yo I have a question or
not somebody's is faster in questions
okay so we're still waiting yeah guys
could we talk about this one that the
one that is black yep so here's here's a
question let's say you're only allowed
to use black and white and if you were
to use hierarchy of hierarchical
typography and you weren't allowed if
you're in my class and you weren't
allowed to use gradient how would you
solve the last names of the designers
and you're only allowed to use two sizes
what would you do two sizes I would make
one of them small awesome so let's try
that I like I like the size of the
features the size ah beautiful look at
that so that's another way of creating
depth so right now I'm noticing in this
design we're creating depth by using
gradient or value but if you ask
yourself what if I can use I should I
what if I'm only allowed to use
typography that's one way now again
everything is relative so let's see what
happens here once we do this because now
we may have too much of small text and
this is when grouping comes in because
if you have a little bit here a little
bit there a little bit over here what
happens if you bring them all together
and
damn for a focal point keep talking it's
gonna take me a little while to do this
you're doing a great job I'm curious to
know how do everyone else feel about
this is this okay nice I like it Chris
that you're beautiful beautiful okay yes
you have children right yes even I think
you're killin even when they're 50 I'm
just saying yeah so are any of them in
design and you know it's interesting my
daughter she's a college student and
she's taking great interest in design
and she just blows me away when she
designs layout for her presentations and
I'm like where did you learn that she
goes mom I learned it from you I'm like
but I never shared these things with you
I'm in class she was mom I said all the
time so she's picking that up and I'm
just really impressed it feels really
good to see when your children have your
DNA yeah just some extent okay I'm going
to just sing I'm going to Arts Center
sorry and what's your okay so let's get
back into the lab we'll talk a little
bit more about your children and their
pursuits in the creative field but you
were talking about grouping so what
where did you want to go with that so
I'm wondering if we take some of the
information at the top bring them in
together and some of the information at
the bottom what if we make the name of
the designers our focal point because
they're big and then the rest of the
information can come together maybe in a
paragraph or two to have their own area
I'm curious to try that okay so be a
little bit more prescriptive when you
describe that so I can actually do this
for you since I have my hands on the
machine here gotcha so Chris what if we
take the word
let's see let's take January away from
where it is to where and then bring it
down and align it with the journal for
uh-huh nice and then and then you guys
can figure out the hierarchy of in terms
of what needs to be read first that's
working up good right now what do you
think about open and close that
paragraph that says open and closed
title design for television should we
move that align left as well what do you
think I care you mean yes yes yes okay
okay we're cleaning things up it's not
there yet but we're cleaning things up
and we're simplifying it and let's zoom
at a little bit more please and then
what if we take do we have what if we
have the words features rotate it
vertically align with the word Sol
Lester and so forth nice okay all right
now not notice what we just created we
just created a prison bar feature and
reason and resonate you guys see that
right so be aware of how these sort of
layouts can create trapped space we just
created a trap space so we need to move
resonate somewhere else let's play that
out play that out Chris but we can
remove the word resonate and move it
somewhere else
okay suggests I was still trying to
follow the prison bars like sometimes I
don't know if you mean literally
figuratively or it's just a story from
your childhood your literal and then
sometimes you're using analogy or right
I work much better like you know telling
you exactly what to do I like to I like
to make you think that's
but you know what happens I'm right now
I'm just trying to move the box
[Laughter]
hey folks this is the second time Chris
and I are working to share with all
right I am NOT okay could we take the
word resonate and then also rotate it
vertically and see what happens that uh
if I could just hit the keys correctly I
Kris I Oh beautiful keep it there Oh
gorgeous
that's your push and pull with the with
the future and resonate yeah you see
that how it's pushing resonating with
ruching and then feature is pulling of
course feature should read upward
mobility but it is it is it right now
but that is a gorgeous area like we zoom
out what do you think Chris what else
can we do oh this comes miss Lin okay I
love the top area by the way I'm not
sure about the bottom though sure so one
of the things I want to drive deeper and
greater contrast is I'm gonna see if I
can change this case to where's my
change case I thought it was here change
case to sentence case and it did nothing
or we can change it to lower case and it
still does nothing okay because it's
probably typed in all uppercase so later
on I'm gonna go and change this to upper
lower case because I think this is the
hero we have to decide and we all can
make different decisions what do we want
to be the hero and this is the hero
basically the artists that are featured
too in this publication so I'm gonna
also try to tighten up the lighting here
right because I want to create a denser
thing and I'm creating more open space
perhaps that's something that you can do
with this is you can really have fun
with this let me try this and let me
open up the tracking to like I don't
know 2500 okay and I was thinking about
this like what if we were able to make
it even greater contrast here so it's a
little dots like and then it's meters
right see now I'm already kind of
talking like you I don't and you
also implementing the push and pull do
folks see that maybe push and pull is
about contrast is how much you how much
of the contrast you bring in with the
principles of design and well actually I
should say elements of design sorry
mm-hmm and I'm gonna go steal my type
here I think it's all in this area here
I'm just gonna copy this because I don't
I'm lazy I don't want to sit here and be
typed the whole thing about what have to
so pace it and make it white come on
color boom all right now what I can do
is I think I can I drop this and make it
all the same stuff oh it is that is
weird I should be able to change the
case now let me just start doing one at
a time change case I'll do the sentence
case it still does nothing I don't
understand why is it the typeface no
okay I give up but basically I was
thinking that this should be upper lower
case and I don't want to really type it
in again so we could try that another
thing that we can try just let's take a
look at it is this is all based on this
one strung grid line this vertical grid
line here okay what if we took this this
all right I'm gonna make sure that
they're aligned some of these my
Pathfinder a kind of alignment tool make
sure it's aligned which it is now what
if we just push it in like what happens
then nice and cool dynamic exists right
so there's lots of things that we can
explore still I think and I I think the
january/february is different kind of
piece of information creating more
separation from that versus the group is
a good thing
and of course when you change one thing
you have to kind of change everything
and you kinda have to look at this the
way that this thing works together and
it's coming together so what happens
yeah the right or the left they it
changes things right maybe I don't like
I like that less but the reason why I
like that less is because there's a lot
more negative space on the upper right
hand corner here this area versus down
here so I don't want to mess that up I
think one last little thing that bothers
me these brackets for the features they
almost at
this point sighs read like other
characters so I may suggest that you
delete those brackets for now to see if
that helps with the legibility and the
sharpness of that point there I don't
know but that's just me okay I think we
should move on yeah okay mark are people
saying go faster go slower and you got
the same pace what are they saying
unanimously faster noka is lightening
around time it is 3:12 we've been on air
now for an hour in 12 minutes
we need to pick up the pace and maybe
look at a few more layouts and just
maybe make some verbal suggestions first
is trying to resolve the whole layout
okay I don't look at this one firm
junior folks what I shared with you
earlier about principles of designs and
element of design think about that in
your next design layout and see how you
can use those to push and pull your work
even further
the class the class has concluded now we
talked about it all okay I want to take
these elements and I want to rotate them
because it's connected to this other
idea that I I think it's important for
it to stay connected to those ideas okay
so it's resonate I still need to kind of
read that that's my one suggestion
there's some spacing issues here when
you look at this it should be closer or
farther I think you need to kind of
figure that out okay and make sure that
these things somehow tied together okay
here's one from Patrick tight tight
tight tight and you don't know what they
actually talking about I'm just saying
you know
blushy Street in the street lingo people
will say that's tight log that's a tight
let it out she thinks she's like
fighting the lighting and the kerning
which I don't think I can because it's
been outlined already which is okay but
you guys have seen plenty of examples
yeah the other thing I want to talk
about is be aware of scattered space
that is gonna kill you there's a lot of
scattered space it's gonna kill your
work metaphorically speaking it's gonna
kill your layout because what happens
with scattered space
flattens it oh my god look at all this
social distancing we're doing scatter
space so we can flatten the curb right
what a good analogy right there you can
complement your own analogy remember I
cut the umbilical cord so I'm not being
subjective okay overall I think this is
a pretty nice layout good good choice of
contrast like really large and breaking
it up
this kind of like flowing like
left-right left-right kind of thing not
always easiest thing to do I think what
what this person did Patrick was to do
this thing I'm feeling this and Patrick
tell me later on the social medias if
I'm making this up tell me if I'm lying
I think what he did was come on man a
computer behaved all right I will make
you okay
I think the logic the rationale behind
the alignment to this is really based on
this nice be that's that's the bone
yeah the bone okay
so that I think so
otherwise it's kind of what's the order
here and then everything else is
scattered around and yeah let's keep
going especially those especially those
two little paragraphs in the middle that
is I'm not happy with those it's
creating a very dead odd space there
there's a lot of scatter space there so
I would rethink where I would put those
ah there you go just with one click see
you tell me the problem okay here's
another layout this is from mozu mo I
put an asterisk here because every time
I open your files it's some typeface I
don't have and that's totally okay next
time you submit something just outline
your type so that I can open it because
it's a pain in the butt for me to go and
convert your files cell font that I
actually have so I can see it
so mozu have you watched this please
convert you're out your typeface or just
use Helvetica don't use some weird
exotic some-some Hong Kong version but
it's kind of tough for me to work with
okay so most really playing around with
color by doing outline using a syllabus
in bold typeface but using outline and
he's also created a little bit of an
illustration here with the resonate kind
of repeating itself like it's rotating
thoughts I like that yeah nice nice
trick okay nice trick okay
anything else I'm with you
I would like about this layer is that he
knows the rules he's very aware of the
rules but then he also when I'm broken
why do I say that is because if you
cover the top right corner if you put a
box there Chris black box yeah you look
at it you go oh wow very clean very
simple beautiful but then he was aware
that it's missing that um and then he
became and then he brought that if you
can take the box away and bring that top
right corner text back in please okay I
didn't mean to do that
I hid it and I don't hurry so come and
see awesome and then now it's there and
I'm like thinking it's here's the thing
cuz he's now having everything on a
great great great great and then also
the boom just big gigantic tags like
look at me it's on 102 2018 and I'm not
thinking I kind of like it he broke the
rules and it it for me it works because
I know that he knows what he's doing
crispy argue with me this layout a
little uncomfortable I have to say it
could just need the bold typeface this
is just me okay boldness of the typeface
and also luckily you picked a big enough
typhus and bold enough to outline
because the really thin type basis of
your to try to outline it like this
would be very very hard to read so I my
whole thing is I want to focus on this
part here I'm gonna move this away so
let's just say we have one trick my
whole thing is one trick per layout
that's it otherwise you're gonna you're
one too many tricks into a show here
right so if I take that and I duplicate
this I'm gonna try this thing where I
change this to the word journal I just
want to try it on one okay and I take
the same thing and I'm gonna use the
same visual language here I'm gonna
rotate it on this point there and I'm
hold on option and I'm gonna do
same thing okay it's not as dense as
that
so the resonate journal and then I want
to do the word graphic down here let's
just say okay oops
hopefully I get someone like what you
think okay before before we say anything
yet hopefully you know and then I'm
gonna take this and I'm also rotated
down this time I'll rotate it much
closer together to get that same guy are
you doing command D yeah I'm doing
command D just right so what I want to
do this is kind of more in the Cal arts
experimental expressive typography
versus functional typography which is
what we try to focus on mostly here but
if you were to take this visual language
and make the most out of what you have
right maybe even overlap here I don't
know it can actually be a really
beautiful psychedelic trippy thing and
then I would have no more tricks on this
page and that would be it
so it could be resonate the journal for
graphic design done in some kind of a
lustrum of way like this and it's like
it's pretty cool it's super trippy
looking right okay yeah so to me right
now the rest of this really is not
important so what I would do is this I
would take all of it and make it small
yeah okay maybe alignment issues here
I'm not sure it feels like it's a little
funky but let's just beautiful all
nicely laid out okay and and then just
kind of simplify everything else to make
this the superstar and how do I do that
I'm gonna make this even smaller that's
eight point okay I still within the
realm of legibility nice yes so we're
gonna drive greater contrast to this
poster of course there's issues here so
I'm gonna I drop that I'm gonna even
make this small too however we do this
that we have one focal point and now
it's almost like layouts busted but you
guys get the idea we'll have something
that's very lyrical some kind of crazy
vibe going on here and then we just keep
working with that that's it okay same
principles fundamental spacing hierarchy
structure and negative space repetition
and contrast but with one flare all
right next one cold razor you talked
about Cole
but we'll know maybe I don't know
anyways kool Fraser really big bold
italic I find italic typefaces a little
bleak in this case or italic hard to use
but I think the most part this is pretty
successful yeah I agree I agree I agree
there's some nudges I would do yes of
course yes get rid of that that's
expected you see that ha ha yeah that
takes at the bottom right corner tells
me with all due respect is that the
designer didn't know what what to do
with that extra text and goes ah there's
a space boom let me attach it there be
aware of that if you ever do that the
design is a relationship it's like
having parent children you know cousins
okay it's not like me and you does that
make sense because now that tap text at
the bottom right corner is so silo I I
have tears for it there's a crocodile by
the way okay couple things question yes
the question is how can we make a
relationship I'm curious to know what if
we do bring it at the very top above I'm
about in the issue and have it italic in
the same axis yes yes that's what I was
thinking as well so I was looking at how
Cole built his file so this file here is
a list so Cole was listening listening
but then when he wants to put an angle
like this
he's literally adding I think spaces in
here let me try yeah he's having spaces
in it so that's one way to do it I'm not
sure another way to do if I draw a text
box I'm going to show you so everybody
is watching right so theoretically if I
drop this text it should be italic as
well right same text it just placeholder
right now so I'm going to delete this
right now
I'm gonna show you how to do that much
easier way if you take the hollow point
or direct selection tool and you just
grab the top and you skew the box you
have your effect you don't have to
possibly hit all the spaces that way all
the text is still nice and easy and you
can work with it and why did I ask you
to do that the reason being
now I could just duplicate this up here
right and I can say like now this is the
resonate part Res
underscore an eight did I do that right
no hate and then January February 2018
okay now that we have elements we can
work with again I'll delete this so I
think that's what Milko was talking
about yeah you're looting
now here's another trick like to draw
the same line up there sometimes that
could be kind of tricky it's not super
tricky but here's another trick if you
select this edge and you copy and you
hit paste command F paste in front and
I'm hit scale I'm gonna scale a sucker
up and now you have a grid line that's
automatically it's gonna be rock-solid
because I know it okay so I'm gonna
color this so you can see that grid line
and now I need to make that line up with
that and there you go okay could you
bring it all the way below the letter C
in the word graphic please yes
ah okay there you go nice and then of
course you know what I'm gonna say about
the letting tie-dye and then doesn't it
look like it's in shape now it looks
like it's been working out and it has
more confidence it knows what it's doing
you have a little problem here I need to
open this the P and tittle of the eye
runs into each other so they're all a
funky so we don't worry so this is where
you go in and you nudge it a little bit
over so you can avoid these little
things we got a nudge it like come on I
call this legal cheating that's what I
[Laughter]
think I'm thinking like maybe driving
lessons or you know driver's ed she
cheating but that's okay okay at night
at the risk of making Nilka freak out on
us I'm gonna do it I'm going to show you
guys something okay yes okay we had this
type and let's just say this is all we
had and we want to play around with this
a little bit more so maybe this is
premature but I'm going to show you guys
a trick to stay tuned for like how this
group moves okay so I'm gonna command
shift oh I'm an outline all that tight
okay and then I'm gonna take this along
this grid point here the same one that
we've established and I'm going to
divide the letters okay so if I were to
cut it it would start to look a little
different so I'm gonna do this in a
non-destructive way here let me just try
this I'm a draw box and I'm gonna take
this box hang in there with me you guys
we're we're cooking with gas here so it
may or may not work I'm gonna hit all of
all these little details that you're
showing us Chris I love it I'm learning
so much from you thank you thanks I'm
learning a lot from
as well I've not taught typed for as
long as you have so okay Simon paces
back in front the last little bit I'm
gonna do is I'm a copy I'm gonna show
you what I'm doing so you can see I'm
taking this box and this type I'm gonna
copy into the memory so I'm copying it
okay and all will be revealed in one
second so I'm gonna look at this again
so now I'm going to take this and hit
command 7 which mask it off to that side
okay
now I'm gonna hit command F and paste
the rest of the back here and I'm gonna
take this side let me hit command 7 and
I can't do that for some reason you zoom
in just a little bit let me hide this
side that's why okay take this and hit
command 7 why didn't I do this oh okay
let me do it one more time
I need to grab this
here we go last time come on please work
yeah boom okay so come on option three
bring it all back okay is my whole thing
nothing is different nothing is
different but milk I knows where I'm
going with this because I can tell I
could just move it I could share it
that's the push and pull we're talking
about beautiful oh my god this is so
gorgeous it's still editable and you
could do not edible and there's no
cannibalism here but you can still edit
all this stuff because the box is
dynamic and I haven't chopped up the
type all right so just some things for
you to think about the reason why I
bring this up and when you're running
out of ideas to try I want to remember
this thing before the advent of desktop
publishing we had to print things out we
had to cut things pasted things together
with very crude tools a typesetter might
do this
so we forget that type used to exists in
a physical form so if you wanted to play
with type and you had to like push
things closer together you become really
aware of space because the black ink
sits on a piece of paper and if there's
really a piece of paper here the paper
can be cut it could be sheared it could
be crumpled it could be folded over it
could be bent and warped and all kinds
of things and it creates another thing
for us to think about another tool in
our toolbox things to try all right so
that's Cole Fraser keep it up I'm gonna
jump to this one Kenta Yoshida this is a
pretty wild layout so I wanted your eyes
on this okay so so this is this is not
reverse and lines for the assignment
that we're having in two weeks no not
yet because because because they're
using lines i streamers
well maybe or this is an eight yeah the
Roman numerals VIII I love it so it's
called legal cheating again no this is
called the light ball goes in your hand
you go ah I love it it's so memorable
for me now and actually this is I'm
really glad you're focusing on this
folks I want to talk about the power of
good design because the power of good
design is
very important for effective
communication and doing good business
now these days if anything we need good
design to make our business event
productive and powerful why because good
design is not just about pretty pictures
it's about using an effective and an
attractive composition like what
Christians demonstrated to you to grab
your attention right to communicate a
purpose a theme a content and awareness
in a meaningful experience and when it's
in meaningful it becomes impactful and
when it's impactful becomes memorable
and then that's when audience wants to
take action their prompt to take action
and this is why good design is good for
good business so this is the end of the
campaign speeches where Milko Brookline
says and i'm milca Brookline and I
approve this message
[Laughter]
there's little details here and I may
have accidentally moved your file but if
I haven't kento this is where like first
we look at the big broad strokes I think
you're getting some praise from Miss
Milko Brooke I'm here and that she's
like hey this is pretty inventive you're
playing around with the components as
you're given and you're giving us a
whole new way of looking at it which I
like I would have thought to do this
myself personally and when you did this
and like huh it's not perfect but I like
to thinking I like that you're pushing
it but when i zoom in this is good
features should sit on the baseline in
this issue sits on the baseline and then
I go up here resonate doesn't sit on the
baseline so maybe I actually moved it
but if I didn't make sure that that all
your details are in place okay I don't
wanna say too much more because the
audience did ask for faster faster more
so we're gonna be faster more let me
weird one
that's a nice one actually this the one
next to the eight number eight that they
wanted the right yeah the heart is the
one that is using OneNote please okay so
it's right next to the eighth numeral
number eight so it's to its left oh this
one this one yes yeah until you Sheeta
yes
yeah what I like about this piece it
right now when I look at it I feel so
calm I feel like I'm in the Zen mood I
love it it's just so clean and crisp I
like the fact that how you did take the
weight that is the lightest and you
enlarged it and that is another way of
creating a very powerful contrast where
you're using thin but you're making it
very large
nice good job Dewey okay here's another
one from Sheriff Dean and I put an
asterisk next to this cuz I had troubles
opening your files as well I think
you're using an exotic version of
Helvetica I think or perhaps totally
different typeface I don't know I had to
convert it to this so Sharif sheriff
make sure you convert your your type
into outlines for me so I can look at
okay if you don't do it moving forward
anybody that sends me something I don't
have I'm just not gonna bother looking
at it because it takes a lot of work for
me to I drop and just change all your
typefaces okay okay sure app good job
with the kerning and tracking a little
tight tight tight all right anything
else yeah there is a scattered islands
that are floating around I like them to
be more connected so let's take some of
those single lines and then maybe we can
rotate them around vertically and then
have them aligned with one of the
strokes of the letters possibly ah
beautiful
let me do this right away come on okay
you wanted to line which way uh maybe we
can align it with one of the strokes so
like the stroke of the letter e okay for
the word da okay that's good that's good
I like it I like it so hot now now that
you did this Chris I'm curious to know
what if we take those body copies on the
left and then bring them hold the shift
key bring them to the right but then
align them with those vertical lines how
would that work
you're good with these okay and then you
can move it up and down possibly yeah
need to tell me and I can move things
you're good with details I'm
[Laughter]
very hands-on I have to go in there and
then move it around so I can tell you
what's working what's not working but
right now what I'm thinking is I'm sorry
to cut you up I apologize beautiful I'm
trying to think how we can create a
relationship where it's not just
segregated islands or silo pieces
sitting there crying for themselves my
type crying for a selfie for so now
you've introduced I know it another way
listen good design is touching the heart
of the brain that's why it's called the
heart the heart of the brain that would
just be called the heart it touches your
heart and then your brain takes action I
see I see
okay so Shroff good layout I think
there's some things to work out I don't
know if we improved anything I'm gonna
move on I just liked it
I think the bold all caps contrasted
with the super small all caps nice
contrast good use of negative space the
details apparently are the things that
separate good typographers from great
typographers and I'm not a great divorce
I want to move on we'll figure it out
later okay you're awesome another one
and I included because I just like the
boldness of this so show off I can tell
even though we don't share the same font
library I can tell you know what you're
doing you're really pushing these around
and I can see that I can appreciate that
I just want to just talk really briefly
maybe the 2018 january/february feel a
little bit out of place here and I'm
gonna just try one thing it may or may
not make it worse I'm gonna just try to
move it over a little bit and see if we
can connect the push pool idea I don't
know if it's working the other thing
that we I have a little problem with is
this space here so you're in that no
persons land or no man's land okay so
that's kind of where you just nudge it
up and you just cut it off should be
okay what do we do with these two
orphans that are crying for themselves
okay okay what I was thinking is I like
what you did Chris what I was thinking
I was curious to know what if we take
the top of resume
and have it aligned with the backbone of
the alignment the vertical alignment yes
of the typography yes uh-huh and then
move it in how much more do you want to
bring it in a lot you know um I I'm
curious to see if we use law of thirds
how is that gonna play itself so maybe
move it all the way to the far right all
right yes and then have those little
tiny texts come out please to the left
and then this is made they make they
could now rotate themselves and become
horizontal and become the satellite that
we're talking about bringing your eye
back in
oops okay okay what if we what if we
increase resonate large enough that it
encompasses the entire length of the
paper and it maybe nudges itself out a
little bit a little bit but that's good
too too much yes maybe a little bit to
our smarter please okay good good good
good all right and then so this way it
looks like you know the page is flowing
around I would even also move the
resonate up maybe two points but I know
you don't like that but I like it the
stroke of our yeah yeah good job good
job
oh that's awesome now all we need to do
is go in there and clean things up like
now how can we align voices in this
issue aligning with the access of the
stroke of the letter N and then maybe
bring the Journal of graphic design down
to the stroke of letter E okay so those
are details we'll work out but we're
yeah we're gonna move fast right so I
want to explain a principle here to our
audience and go to properties here I'm
gonna go and beef up this line so you
guys can see a little bit better on line
add an arrow here again okay so what we
have right now is we have two major
elements well and we have a third kind
of less major element this thing we're
here it is all very vertical right so
Milko was talking before about the push
and the pull and to these elements to me
describe the same unit which is
basically the vertical dimensions of the
page so I'm gonna hide this for a second
so I thought maybe what if we tried this
what if we took let me group this let me
take this and shift it it up okay in a
way that's no good let me try it again
let me do you select this and shift it
up let me just try and then let me make
this the same
as of that so if I go and put the point
here scale it down so it's roughly the
same size like this not quite there yet
I'm holding on shift here so I don't
accidentally okay so before we had these
two arrows right and it's still
essentially the same concept but when we
talk about the push-pull what if we made
one of these things offset like this and
I couldn't do that before because it was
too big that's too big it's too big so
let me delete that and I could take this
and I could do the push-pull thing yeah
how does that make you guys feel so
these are things we want you to think
about milk on high and now I think I can
bring this in closer and let's pretend
that those were aligned and this was
aligned and I know it's not guys but I
don't wanna get into that and then we
can see like what what happens when this
is shifted up and down and what kind of
rhythms are we creating here is it
better is it worse you know okay I feel
like we need mint in here so we're gonna
cheat legally cheating once again honey
you're watching okay let's just say it's
like so that we know that one doesn't -
might 3/3 creates a pattern 1 2 3 this
is good this is good so we can push and
pull so if we want to make this dance a
little bit more we can do this thing
where you've got 3 elements so I'm gonna
show you what this looks like I have 3
equal elements right and if I take one
element and these 3 bars represent these
3 things that we see here that's kind of
interesting but if I were to create this
thing that's evenly uneven and I take
two yes right oops right right and we
can even push it apart there's lots of
things that we can do this is teaching
you about composition and design right
I'm gonna delete this now I could
probably take this group nice example of
Chris very nice thank you so I can take
this group I maybe I make it lower and
higher and we can explore what this
looks like I see I know
no couple and I we both like that visual
tension and things cutting off the page
so this is
he goes down it dips down to the valley
and goes straight to the peak at the top
of the mountain it guys okay I don't
think this is cutting off enough for me
yeah explain why I like that why are we
doing that look when you see a little
bit of this curve come back in this
creates a weird shape there you see that
little thing so yeah so when it curves
back in it still bothers me so I like it
so like where it feels like there it's a
purposeful cut there's good in like a
lot of intention beyond that and then so
that's it's rough that's what we think
we've already done this layout I think
we've talked about good job good job
good job overall let's find another job
everyone here let's look at this one
johannes yella more Gellin johannes
yellow maybe what do you think about
this layout tell us how you really feel
I'm confused
there's a lot of scattered space there's
not enough contrast
I like the idea behind it where the
focus is on resonate and it's like
buzzing around I really like the idea
but the forum hasn't followed the
function and I think you guys haven't
heard about form follows function right
we have about it oh okay see a pretty
picture becomes only effective and
powerful when there's a purpose behind
it right right now did we do have a
purpose but the form is not following
the purpose it wants to but it's not
there and that's exactly why you are all
taking this class and learning from
Cristo how to become beautiful form
makers because when you become beautiful
form makers then you can communicate the
purpose and make it very effective and
powerful and make that good for good
business yeah so right Chris
right absolutely yeah so this is not
there yet I like the idea but it's not
there at all
okay I want to talk about that a little
bit so and I'm gonna read some comments
seeing this kind of funny what's
happening okay this is johannes Yellen
and I again I I like to pull out the
anomalies because there's a lot of
people who are doing the same thing over
and over again so just because they
don't talk about you doesn't mean that
your layout is not good or it's bad it's
just because I'm looking for something
to bite into and so everything is really
simple you you're doing one trick excuse
me which I know yet it is a buzzing kind
of vibe and and you can say hey this is
about the art world and the buzz that
these artists are creating you could
justify it that way if you wanted to my
only comment to you it's a very simple
one is for something that's random there
is a lot of order to this which I think
you need to work on so you see how like
if I were to draw a line here you see
that line ladies and gentlemen of the
jury it's almost like there's too much
conscious thought into a random layout
which is really hard to to break like
once you learn how to do these kinds of
layouts you have to sit here and it's
like a painter like where do I put these
things so that it's even but it's uneven
and it's not easy to do
so it takes a lot of skill to be able to
arrange this so it feels scattered
there's a sense of balance but it
doesn't feel too heavy-handed like it's
contrived so work on that but I do think
that you're doing all the right things
you're using contrasting point sizes
you're relying on one trick and there's
a lot of negative space here and this is
how you do this okay imagine this could
work for a lot of different applications
so I want to keep encouraging you do
this Johannes now I'm gonna take a
moment here why don't I park it on a
layout that needs a little thought let's
see there's a lot for us to look at here
here I'm gonna focus on this one right
here so this is from Alex I can there's
a party going on there's a partay
now I'm gonna read some of the comments
because they're just too funny for me
not to read I think you being on the
show has added a lot of color commentary
and fun flavorful expressions that
people are just laughing about so Carlos
is like lmao and in Carlos Assange type
cries there's there's a lot of funny
little comments going on here you have
to read these comments later a MC is
you touch the lung of my liver I'm so
I'm so honored because that made you
think and you came up with your own
analogy good job good job yes yes
so just in case you don't know both both
no kind I English is not our first
language I don't know if you could tell
both of us English is not her first
language my first thing I didn't know
that about you yeah
and what is your first language Farsi
Farsi see so I love having people that
English is not their native tongue the
mother tongue so they add like colorful
expressions I just I dance on it so
there you go let's get into it yes Alex
crackin
so what's cracking Alex okay nOCA Oh
Alex said this is a really fun piece to
look at my eye right now is not reading
but my eye is dancing I hear music I
hear like there's this music happening
am i I wants to jump around yeah so if
this was a flyer let's say for a DJ a
cool awesome DJ called ez n resonate I
think this was this would be a good
flyer moving forward but if you want
this to be more structure and follow the
rules that Chris is teaching you then
you might want to type the space between
the islands of the text a little a
little bit more there's too many scatter
space right now so the question is
where's the focal point nice Chris thank
you yes beautiful and how we can group
things together so they speak to each
other better and there's more unity
that's how you create unity you bring
things together I we did talk about
having three groups large medium small
but at the same token you want to make
sure that they speak to one another
they're not just somewhere along by
themselves mm-hmm now I think
alex has a very good eye for composition
i think instinctively he knows how to
make these very asymmetrical layouts
work because he's repeating all these
elements everywhere and i can see that
it's it's almost like his backgrounds in
painting or something i can tell like
there's these grid lines that he's
imagining and he's dabbing little bits
of paint onto the canvas and i get that
how can we do this working with what we
have and not have to rely on repeating
resonate so many times i also want to
say this to everybody that's working on
this assignment i know that the
assignment has been updated so many of
you guys are coming from the legacy
group when this course was created and
you're just submitting old work which i
think is fine but just do me a favor
just convert the cut type to match up so
we can't tell that little bit of effort
would mean the world to me to say like
you care enough that you're actually
trying to conform to what we're doing
okay i just i'm not gonna mention again
i'm just saying please do that because
then it feels like you're participating
live with this even though you took the
course a long time ago there's a lot of
things that i like about this it's very
difficult to do these kinds of layouts
with this off-axis grid and shifting
things around it would take me too long
to kind of massage all this stuff but
the one thing i wanted to do is tighten
up the space and create that really
strong grid point which is right here my
computer's artichoke now increase while
you're explaining that i want to bring
to your attention that notice that how
if you squint your eyes because I see
this as a form rather than reading it if
you squint your eyes
the letters InDesign issue resonate
features they're almost the same length
almost
and that is gonna flatten your piece and
they're scattered to some extent be
aware of scatter nests and be aware of
same length almost saying if anything is
almost the same measurement be aware of
that bring them together create focal
point by proximity yep okay so good job
Alex on that I like the exploration and
kind of on that note so that for some
reason I pasted three diagonal kind of
off axis layouts together so I'm gonna
just really quickly talk about these and
then we're gonna move on okay and if you
want to add anything Milka go ahead so
this is from Jordan dandelo and there's
a strong access here resonate in this
issue features there's maybe it feels a
little disorganized with the way that
these things are just dropping in here I
hope you guys can see that I think we
probably need just that just more firmly
established one focal point one grid
line and it feels like it's a little bit
all over the place sometimes you push
and pull and you can push so hard that
it's starting it becomes very difficult
for us to find the composition again all
right let me say that and Milcah if you
don't have any if you atom and move on
okay yeah this is a nice piece it has a
lot of potentials to make itself even
better and this is my personal opinion
but every piece that I look at it any
good piece any good piece there's always
potentials for making it different or
better you can say but this has a good
start and he has a good access and I
like how he is aware of pushing the eye
to the top of the page and then bringing
it back down but it's at this moment
there just to recall it's sandwiching it
there we go okay sandwich carbs so let's
people [ __ ] we should keep track of all
these metaphors we're talking about okay
so this is going using the same
principles we've been talking about this
type seems really small but seven-point
okay I think when you get to seven six
point it's getting really small
especially when you use thin and or a
lightweight typeface so this is thin at
that point sighs if this were ever to be
printed or something
it's the integrity of the letter forms
are starting to break okay so you need
to be cognizant when you choose the
weight not to go too small it looks okay
on screen and if you move off screen it
can be problematic so this is from
tirage and Suraj is doing the thing that
we talked about breaking the list
creating that visual tension wrapping
around yeah which in the pool there's
some spacing issues it feels a little
too even in the middle here and I think
the january/february feels a little
lonely it's crying I think maybe and
maybe we can bring it back to the family
somehow maybe by pushing it closer I'm
not sure yet dad could act as your
satellite versus I'll talk more about
that cuz when you when you have when you
have a corner and then at the bottom
right corner there's an empty space and
you put something there that's a lonely
space but here it's talking to the axis
I see thank you thank you for asking all
these good questions right so if this
January February stay up here Oh what is
going on okay let me lock this somehow
this is about my background layer
hygiene okay yeah I'm gonna bring it up
here and then I'm gonna rotate it like
yes yes okay yes yes good job good job
rise right cuz it's like it's just I'm
here I don't know what to do with it and
I'm not related to anybody
my family's left me and you nailed it
okay thank you Chris I'm glad that we
had that clarification yes thank you for
pushing it oh here's another one from
I'm not nice yeah it's very famous fight
a lot of open space yeah gracious no
space this is the piece that could use a
satellite to bring your eye back in
because right now my eye is very much
focused on the bottom left area but the
top right something small something okay
yeah that sounds good no yeah that's
your satellite there you go something
yeah that's what you're saying your back
alright so now the white space is being
used to
next forms with this one another yes so
here is okay and this mm-hmm are saying
that I didn't create all this white
space to ignore it I created it so I
want you to like get a little taste of
it I'm just probably it's a teaser right
yeah it's a teaser it's a satellite
brings your by it I backing it's the
moon it's a job beautiful okay I think
I'm I don't think I am tired now it's a
lot of brain worth looking at this stuff
and trying to figure it out anyone here
that call attention to your eye that you
want to talk about
see Chris that's another good example
the bottom the second one from the
bottom right that's a good example this
one that we can talk yes let's talk
about this please Keith Cox yeah I I
want to talk about this whoever did this
I don't want to who did it thank you for
doing it because it's about to work it's
about to work we want to focus on the
work I like the act notice here's what's
happening two things are happening here
that I want you to be aware of number
one we've got a big chunk of white space
at the bottom right corner right yes
yeah thank you so much it's doing
nothing all right number two you've got
these vertical I'm sorry this lines of
45 degree angles lines that are
happening and then at the top we've got
these horizontal lines they're not
talking to each other are they oh I just
want to say this one is saying this one
is speaking one language Philippine
maybe and then the other my speaking
Farsi
[Laughter]
okay summer forgot to turn off their
bike okay so usually when you do that
you're like somebody's talking Farsi and
somebody socked in Arabic and now you're
losing Filipino to college and in Farsi
it's like keep it in the same region
okay and taught but you said you speak
Philippine so I I'm not Filipino I may
look like it what I'm not Filipino did
you say you speak the language I do
minimis okay Vietnamese I'm sorry Chris
I apologize I don't know why I heard
that Marcus rolling his eyes right now
because he is Filipino all right so
there there's this is presenting a
design challenge for us right Milka like
whoever this person is Keith Cox is
exploring this and we like that and I
like that you're trying something here
again this is not something I would
think of naturally to try to rotate the
type and get it to line up on this left
edge and I think Keith is doing the same
thing where he's using spaces to do this
and there's a lot of different ways to
do this but this is probably the most
laborious time-consuming way to do it
and may I bring one more seat to your
attention is that be aware of the margin
look at the margin right if you can show
the margin to us crispies what is the
matter mark the margin is the edge of
the paper the white space that's the
white space around the edge of the paper
aha exactly left edge yeah that margin
all around the left margin that top
margin and the right margin and of
course there's no margin at the bottom
be aware of that because this is what's
boxing the information inside the paper
is that what you want to do do you want
to box them in that's something to
consider about as well okay fantastic so
let me zoom back out let's do the one
last one that let's get out of here
anything scream at you
nOCA I'm thinking I said we were gonna
ask other people okay it's just us I see
the same thing like for instance
happening with the bottom the second one
from the bottom right I see the same
thing happening with there's text and
then there's space okay if you're gonna
be a minimalist be a minimalist right
now it looks like you put some text in
there and then you're trying to be a
minimalist with all due respect but if
you're gonna be a minimus it has to be
really clean right now this is not
massage yet it needs to go to them
it needs to go exercise and get in shape
more okay let's get in shape so let's
talk about a couple things
I just realized here that you're using
two different weights believe it or not
because using the oblique and the
regular so we would consider a to weight
so this is now not legal cheating you've
been caught on camera oh and on the show
cheaters so we want to get this back to
the way that everything else looks right
so let's so there's our thing yeah so
this resonate if we just scaled it down
a little bit
sorry right we just get it a little bit
we're gonna give some some space to
breathe here some some something for AI
to move around the other thing that I
want to look at is this is this typeface
at this point sighs I'm sorry could be a
little bit smaller and it'll create
greater contrast so right now it's 8
points so we're still good the hierarchy
of the information seems a little weird
because usually this come and lock this
because it's bugging me this piece
information shoot this piece of
information it's confusing to me because
is it related to this or it's related to
this well it's related to this for sure
but it's colored differently this is
black this is gray and it really needs
to kind of be the same color so I'm
gonna do that because that tells me it's
there they belong where has this
information which is completely divorced
from resonate is logically should be
grouped here so we have some order kind
of logic things that we need to figure
out so I'm not gonna be able to fix the
layout right now but these are things
that you're gonna have to resolve okay
so in terms of just the grouping of
information this is a better grouping
because resonate and this that makes
sense to me then you have I'm gonna free
up some of this I just locked that I'm
yeah lock it
I don't move this over a little bit to
let that breathe and probably I need to
scale this down even more and eventually
somewhere here we'll start to create a
layout I'm not sure that this is it but
those are some of the problems make sure
you're using just the parameters we're
giving you in picking one weight and
folks we talked about a lot of good
things and I'm excited that all of these
things that we talked about will be
implemented in your work next work next
week's work or even in your professional
design work that you're doing implement
them write them down shut them down and
make sure that you exercise them so
you'll remember and it will be embedded
in you and you practice and then you can
come back and challenge us and say hey I
did what you asked me to do but it's not
working so we can move and push you even
further than that I like that line Chris
beautiful thank you okay so it's
starting to take shape and we can create
that minimal thing and what the
hierarchy is correct the grouping is
correct we still have some issues with
up and down here the features and in
this issue something that we'll need to
resolve at some point but not right now
okay well let's let's stop here I'm
gonna take a take a break I'm a hit stop
I'm gonna stop to share I want to talk
to everybody it's kind of in our class
all 28 participants let's have a little
conversation this week presented new
challenges for you and we warned you
last week that by having more parameters
fewer limitations more choices and
options actually becomes more confusing
but I think this is the first time that
you get to explore two point sizes and
it creates so much more visual contrast
between the big and the small you guys
care to reflect or share either how you
felt about doing this assignment what
you've learned or what you still
struggle with I'm open to having a
conversation
with you right now okay yes
so that's Lars Lars yeah hi I found it
much easier to work with contrasting
point sizes than contrasting weights
could you explain what the reasoning
behind that might be yes because you can
go from 200 point type to 8 point type
and the amount of contrast that you can
create there is on orders of magnitude
much greater and then the bold is bold
like extra black and so thin all right
so that those are contrasting next to
each other but not like this contrast
see so that's why I think you get to use
space much more creatively when you have
those big elements and those little
elements so so gun to head if somebody
had asked you for the rest of your life
you can either use two weights or two
point sizes you know which one you're
gonna pick two points is definitely okay
good good observation good question
somebody else who's live with us
okay Yuji what's up hey Chris thanks
again for the great critique for me it
was four times harder than the first one
because I realized that I this first my
decision was to decide which one is the
hero so it could be the 2018 or it could
be the title so deciding on that and
then trying to learn the shape of the
word took me time to took me time to
understand and place it where I could
create the most contrast so it took me
more time because I had more decisions
to make yes and that's usually what
happens and it's only and they get more
complicated as we give you fewer
constraints to work with this is why
Nilka has in her class expressed to the
class you're not allowed to use texture
color grainy and transparency because
she wants to make sure that you
understand the fundamentals and this is
where I'm a little bit more loose and
kind of free going and it can create
danger and and it's obvious now because
if you haven't mastered the fundamentals
as we add more things to arsenal of
things to try it's gonna get worse I
mean meaning literally your layout is
gonna get worse and worse because you
haven't
built it on a solid foundation of
understanding of typography you're not
speaking to the heart of the brain or
the lung to deliver its really okay so
there you are so that's what's happening
so let me make sure make sure you you
don't go off the rails and try all the
tricks cuz I do I havin a lot of fun
then the seven weeks you're not that
much better at doing type that's the
danger okay mo Mo's that moves in the
house mo what's up pretty hard because
for the super big size I like you both
typefaces because supple weights because
that's what looks better but when you
actually shrink it down to small it does
not look as pretty as too lightweight so
I feel like this if I want to create a
huge contrast between big and small
using one weights is pretty difficult so
I'm looking forward to the next week's
well we can use more and creating the
more dynamic designs yeah so mark next
week we're doing I believe two point
sizes in two weights right yes sir
oh your wishes will come true mo now
here's a lot I do want to say this the
point of having so many constraints is
this is that you actually learn to
appreciate what you have
so creativity to me isn't that you have
a million dollars and a cast of 100 with
four famous actors it's actually you
have no talent you have no money and you
have the point-and-shoot camera that you
own
that's where creativity comes in so when
you learn the characteristics of a bold
typeface and the thin typeface you can
make it work big small sideways upside
down you can make it work if you had to
if you had to tie nOCA and I in turn
with one hand give us one point size one
weight and we can only use our or one
hand to design I'm pretty confident that
she'll do a good layout and I'll do an
okay one you know that's the thing
that's the kind of confidence that you
want to get to that you can design
anything with anything that you're given
that's the goal that's how you know
you're good too
signer and once you have that inside of
you nobody nobody can take that away
from you and you're gonna walk into that
room with that client or that art
director and feel like I have control
over this I'm no longer a slave to the
type the type yeah like I'm the last
type bender you know like just put a tea
here boom I been type okay who else who
else wants to say something before we
wrap up the show okay
garage yeah so I do get an understanding
of how the satellite it works because
the is it when you placing the type at
an axis it works at its best or is it
when the type is really yeah let me take
a stab at explaining it so tirage is
wondering why does Miss Milkha sometimes
say I love the satellite and sometimes
she's like that child is crying many
tears right now without a mother without
a father with a family totally on their
own why why do you okay in her rationale
is when an element feels like we don't
know what to do with it and we just put
it somewhere on the screen that's the
effect and you know this because when
you guys come up with really interesting
layouts you're like oh shoot
I still have another piece of
information but every time I put that in
there it breaks the layout this is
what's happening because it's not having
any kind of relationship to any other
element it's either off on its own
access or it doesn't align to anything
else on the screen we just don't know
what the heck that thing is exactly okay
that's the problem
and if you get the chance to revisit
what Chris did he did a beautiful
example of how showing the orphan versus
the satellite we need to keep this all
on space analogies or all on anatomical
analogies because you're using what they
call mixed metaphors there's a satellite
and there's an orphan okay was that okay
imagine that okay guys this is it Jonah
let's let's get ready to get out of the
show mourning you right now so guys I
hope you've enjoyed this this super
jam-packed super dense conversation
about typography what we can do with our
layouts
you guys that are enrolled in a course
please make sure you don't use the Hong
Kong version of Helvetica I have
Helvetica I have Helvetica neue I have a
Helvetica now so if you use any other
type face
that's called Helvetica I just don't
have it I'm sorry I just don't have it
so in that case convert your layout to
outlines and if you've done this
assignment before with us please just
update the copy to reflect what we're
doing
hopefully you're applying some of the
principles and not just admitting
homework that you did two years ago
that would go against the point of all
this and on behalf of the entire team
and deep heartfelt heart to brain thank
you to Milka realtime for coming on the
show I hope you join us again see you
guys next time I'm out here have a great
weekend